这开始你的用户怎么来了
观众中里面有一些秘密
观众里面有什么
对你真正的突破
是在你的弱务关系而不是想
然后那一会儿呢
我们就觉得你穿一失败了
之后你就会觉得说我
我干嘛呢
对吧
我还想穿叶
但是你没有
你也有失败了
你讲不出来现在故事
是的
然后呢
而是当时你穿叶并不是说那种
就是你一直很生生这碰
连续穿叶者也没有
然后你经常说
那找不什么公司带着呢
对
所以依赶而去
又重招了
那
这次我打工
我的去个好行业
对吧
现在是什么行业热门
我去什么行业
所以就选择了一家
当时多不量一聊的
就等着什么大健康
不量一聊
一家
好像就感觉挺实上
而且数据很值钱
是吗
就你给了自己
大堆媒体的许识
然后呢
就去了
就说压工促行认识
对
知道
那那那那那那这是
但你去了之后你就会发现
这时候其实我还一直在骗自己
为什么呢
我在骗自己是说
做医疗
都没有
使命感的
因为我觉得
我需要负与意
然后你觉得说
智兵啊
救人啊
这个事是很有
很有道德有事的
是的
我就一直给自己许识
这时候有一次
才会有一次
我相信我们
今天很多人做一些事
也会觉得说
是不是当老师的挺好
对吧
那教书与人
是
是不是当医生特别好
就死出生
就死不生
对我们都会有很多
这样的
标签
但实际上
你自己真正喜欢不喜欢
这个事
你只要问的
对吧
我觉得当然
应该是御华吧
御华应该是也是阿姨
是
后来他就变成些小说了嘛
那你敢不但承认
你自己真正喜欢的事
就是那个
看着别人很不重警的事情
我觉得这事我在里面
干了净净
干了三年之后
可能之子也很高
我没做了很多事
也确实帮到了很多事
帮
我去过很多
一线的那种
小线承
然后那看到一些病人
也看到我一些医生
我们确实帮到他了
你确实帮我承认就赶
但是
晚上你都会觉得说
我这位子就这样嘛
因为回到了之前我说
那个我会担心
这事不是我真正
喜欢的剧本
还是说别人
给我的一个剧本
对
因为那块其实
别人会觉得说
你那儿有很多医生
自现将来有什么事
你就不用吵了
听起来
好像是
对吧
然后你那儿
就是搞医疑了
可能这位子中却放了
好像是
他也是认识
你总会觉得
当你打开
楼圣的时候
我就是要插着楼圣了
你会觉得说
啥时候我们做一个这样的尝试一下
我也有关系我们
对
还没说怎么做出来的
我好棒啊
这个就这样的好贞啊
对
看他怎么想的
为什么我没做出来
为什么我想不到
他其实不是软件开发技术
他是一种思想
是一种
那高思维的一种技术
是的
其实因为很多很多年转
我们
我们就已经有这种
设计产品的理念
要原子换
高内具帝我和这种试动的
对
只是那一刻你看到说
一个人类
可以如此优雅的
实现这么一款产品
是的
然后你就会觉得
特别想
你说膨脏也好
你说欲望也好
你就觉得说
我想要建造一个
那样的东西
所以那个最高风
就来自于说
我在那家公司里面
可能有一次是
在商业
在谈要品工一列
我们像把他某个
要品带个压眼
我谈得很累
我就记下楼吹风
然后呢
吹风的时候
你发现都是发了一个新版
应该是
支持了那个触据库
等着那一会儿
刚知是触据库
一边看各种
媒体的报道
那个那会儿
看各种那种
什么
西方媒体的报道
对吧
然后一边
有觉得说
我今天还
飞了一下
我压了两毛钱
就是
对
然后两毛钱
两毛钱
改变世界
然后呢
你在看到
他的介绍某
当时记得
那房台
因为你知道
他就会讲说
我们没有发明东西
我们只是记得
在太德
女儿
身在上途计话里面
这么怎么样
对吧
然后记成了那个
叛丰凯的一些
什么什么
思想
增加认为之力
这是他们在做的事情
我在谈一毛钱
一毛钱
他们在做的事情
那人崩溃了
你知道
整个人很崩溃
是我的利益
你那些
真正想做的那个
是他
在呀
不知了
不管他给你多少钱
给你多少的
台头
给你自己给你什么东西
你快
认不住要做那个事情
就那一刻
我觉得说
那事不是
就是我想做的事情
而那一刻
我觉得
一个很装的点
就是
他是一个案件
对
就很多人觉得说
我好像也没啥喜欢
我好像也没啥
喜欢的
我这样的话
当当这么多年
是
可能问我
你怎么找到
喜欢的事
那一刻
其实我
当时有一个想法
或者一个
一个思路吧
你回头看
在任何
显下来的时候
空下的时候
不上班不工作的时候
然后你在做哪些
些创造里的事情
这个创造是说
我
五中生有
比如说你
你就说你写的小小小
小老子
小日子
搭搭了网上
这是一种创造
因为在你之前
如果没有胡资哥
没有你写
这篇文章是
不存在有这个世界的事情
他不是小费
小费就说
我刚才会说
看那个满话
哪怕你看完
把树写的个树费
那就是一种创造
所以你回头来看
可能三年五年
因为年纪月大本也好
你看在什么时间
你想创造
哪怕就是
我就想做一创
可是想做好一创
这个东西
而且他一根现成
从五年前
时间跟你有一只在做
说的
那件事
大概率
可能是
你喜欢的事情
只是很多时候
你不敢承认吧
所以那刻才让我觉得说
好像可以开始
一趟新的旅程
所以又过了四年
还是三十五年
对
三十五最很不错
你前面那个是要交学费的
对 学费啊
他和我们的
他和我们的市场环境
和我们的认知
对不起
对吧
就是你只要走出来
然后没有人帮助你
没有人实惦你
你就是要
大概率就是要进攻那个时间
你自己碰壮自己去反思
总结
最后你会发现
好了
这个时间的学费
交播了
对
所以
其实
其实我觉得
你这样才我们俩也了了
很多忙
我觉得
我之前对你做的事情
有一些课缝
或者我有一些
没有那么的赌订
是
但我今天觉得
他是有意义的
对
你说我们说有意的那种
中间的老师
但是我觉得
真的在某一个时刻
你可能
因为在我们直上的人
觉得说
你们说这玩耳神
不玩玩耳神
长时
不值得一讲
没错
你让你比如那玩耳
或者让谁
看我们俩说的东西
那玩耳神
你可能看得
对
那玩耳神
那玩耳看
我们俩在聊
不过俩的东西
都觉得说什么小儿
课对吧
但是可能真的有一些人
他真的是不知道
而且他也没有
取到去找到这样的人
是的
但是连这关键词都搜不出来
那玩耳三个
都是怎么打的
都不知道的
当那可能
机约巧合看到了你的视频
解答他的一个混伙
我觉得他就有
存在的意义在这儿了
然后我之前也觉得说
为什么这种人
显得一种
很烂的书或者这么长时的书
但我现在我才开始理解他
就是真的有人
需要这样的东西
你不能拿你
今天就審试当时
对所以我就开始理解说
你做的这些事是有意义的
我做今天这个事情
只有一个原因的
就是我当年到一北大旁听的时候
我想做一些事情
没有人告诉我改成自己
然后我就创业
我也不知道
我忘了一个方向
我应该学什么
遇到问题
应该怎么做
没有人说
我用我的视角告诉你
可以怎么做
或者你遇到的问题的时候
你说找一个人
帮我提供一些建议
或者想法
没有人告诉你
那个时候我是多么想
有人能告诉我这样的事情
没有
那你会发现
像你也好像我也好
其实走得很重要
我是
所以我后来就想
如果有时间的话
我就把我自己
知道一些东西分享的
反正
我也不要钱
我也我也
你要我不是不卖课
但是我做短视频之前
我是讲课的
我的课程非常高
但是
就是因为到了平台之后
我反而觉得
他实现的意义会有没有
就是我把我知道一些东西
告诉别人
那你知道的
你知道的
那你不知道的话
可能这一句话
可能就
就帮助你了
所以今天其实
我觉得我们聊到
刚才讲了很多的故事
我也希望说
能少走一点
万能少走一点
适合的
能一年
肯定不可避免失败的
但是你能一年失败
就不要像我张成三年
对
我觉得这可能是
就很想跟大家讲的东西吧
对 包括你像
一员照你刚才讲的那个那个那个
那个刚刚刚刚刚刚刚刚
你看他讲的阿倫凯
对
对吧
讲到你这三
对
其实这个就是偶像的力量
是
这就是前面的力量
你看有一些是我们在讲
这的时候好多人是不知道的
不知道谁是那个三
对
不知道谁是阿倫凯
对吧
但是我们如果高软件的人
我们就知道
阿倫凯是谁
对对对对
其实那阿倫凯是谁
他就是把他
的世界观众讲究
丁事的
然后我们去
我们去实现
所以我们
我个人
也和很多人
在聊说
一个最好的方法是什么
是看那些优秀的人
是过去的人
做出成的人
他们给你说的话
你要认真听是的
是的
对
所以在那之后
可能我就开始这次成也的
就是做
但是很近运了
遇到我现在的合伙人
白光
对
老朋友吗
老朋友
对于起来
他对我的影响很大
所以他就
我们俩就聊嘛
就说这次
我们能不能不种子
就开始反常事了
就是我们能不能不种子
但是他说这是常事
因为风险投资
但是声也没多少年
也就几十年
小几十年而已
对吧
他带这之前
很多人都是
罗夏开小麦布
他这一点一点
就像第一天调整片
看小麦布
不能第一天就陪调
是的
对吧
当然我们能不能不种子
我们能不能不做大
是
就不要那个被人
举着非得上市
然后我们能
都做一些好玩的事情
并且挣钱
不要做工艺
我们说工艺
就说那种就是陪调
不说工艺
像我们不好
那是
做那种完全不受费
是的
然后全是纯粹为了这种
个人的什么
什么想
未冒想知
习这种东西
其实又回到
就会调到你原来
那种
我要到计光的人下
我要怎么样
是吧
所以
经过这些反常是我们俩说行
我们就开始做了
弗洞
做了找包图
过没有我跟他一起
收过了
目布
看出了这些事情
我觉得这是一种
另外一个公司主要选
我记得
我记得大被喊连喊森
假深不得一个额
他们也曾经提到
我说
这个事实上有两种
种子
一种公司就是
我要主公司
赚钱赚钱赚钱
上市然后赚钱
另外一种是
我到我的生活
我到我生活哲学
我对这个势力
也融入到我的产品里
对吧
比如说
我能不能
不上市
我对公司
就是不上市的
对吧
我不要融资
我就是要
就是要去
我可能就要有信任用
然后我就是需要
收费
然后我通过收费
来厌证我给你
有没有给你吃了
价值
对
这个社会
并顾缺少一个
不收费的垃圾
是的
但我们可以通过
收费
来给这个社会
创造更大的价值
是的
是价的
所以我觉得
另外一种生活
我也
我看你的产品
其实我都能看到
像大便海铁汉森
那比资客一步
他们这样的一套
是要一套生活的
是的
很好
公司不用拍的
是的
对所以
就是在那刻
也是35岁的开算
拿到了一点点自己的努力
然后再开始去做这样的事情
是的
对
因为我自己是
柔某的场景
不忙
就我从佛罗梦里
能够看到你们的
那个
那个生活有限
包括
没有那么多的功能
是
他就是一个简单的
然后文单里边
可能就会加速
对
有个废晃
加速不要晃
对那样
没了
然后没有
我很喜欢
我非常喜欢
就是
我不喜欢那么多功能
我以前是用上笔记的
后来他功能越来越多
我就不用了
是
包括我以前是用过的的
你功能越来越多
我就不用
有些时候
在某种场景下
我就需要
我就需要存在一些
所以我看你那个产品
不是说
我不能下
因为对我实现来说
跌下一个功能是很
都在的
其实没放出来
对
可是很容易的
这个没有什么技术难度
对
该计划代碗的话
但是我想
无论是
乔伯思要好
还是战好文章
都讲过这个概念
对
关于把一款产品做好
我有以前的主意
对
但是
我比较棒的一点
就是我知道哪些东西
我不需要
对
其实这里边
我对
也跟某种
一上跟人生的选择
也很像
不是我们之所以成为
今天
比如胡德哥
之最成为胡子哥
不是因为你做了什么事
是因为你没做什么事
特别了
假如你今天
这歌就才歌得很凶
对吧
我们没有心情的放谈
对对对
我们俩都很能见不见不见
对
比如假如我这边
就是没有放弃那些
那些哪种
子录或者这两个机会
那我可能今天也不会做在这
是的
所以不管是产品也好
我人也好
不是因为你做的事
速到了
你要是你放弃了
什么机会
来速到了你
而这里面
我就还有一肯狀的事
就当你能全然
拥有一个事的时候
你的放弃才有力量
是的
就是
如果我都
根本没有人愿意投资
我不是根本没有人愿意看我的东西
那这是我说
我不看
我不关系
你这不是
第二道领吗
你就回到你第一次創业那个中
对对对
我们真正有领导是说
我明确的知道
这个东西我能做
我就是不做
这是我才强有力的选择
我的这个是很重要的
你一个认知吧
我觉得这个时候开始自信了
对
是吧
开始自信了
第一次的时候是膨胀
那那个膨胀里的
是自背
对吧
就好像我出门带个机箱的样子
反而是在机箱的样子
基本上没钱
对吧
还有钱的人不会这么带
这么粗的
对对吧
我们就不只低于了
但是这么粗大心想的
基本上可能没钱
对
你看我们还好都有钱
真正有钱
或者真正有什么的
它其实是没有我们
所以都是很普途
很普途
那我觉得这个时候开始
开始有自信了
服务
我看最近有一个
小子心工的
开始加压了
对
怎么理解
我我是总觉得当时
就是内邦气算机线
区门的概念非常认可
因为我们今天用的
所有的设备
都是从那个时代过来的
对吧
然后它里面有一个很装的概念
是增强人类的智力
我觉得我们是应该是
以这个视角来看来它的
就AI其实也是在增强
我们的人类的智力
如果作为一个人
我觉得我们应该有信心
价于人类传到的动作
我的这个
这是一个无理有的相信
因为很多人我觉得
今天是恐慌
或者是焦慮
对但是你想想
焦慮多了
像我们可能
iPhone刚刚一出来说
我妹教练
你懂过两个网络吧
对吧
是不是改变
焦慮已经出来之后
会觉得说
完蛋了
传统组织管要崩溃了
对
那我们都崩溃的这么多年
我们不是还好了
坐在这儿吗
所以我觉得
我觉得第一是
它是一个增强人类的智力的工具
非常好
我们应该是
很有信心的继续系统
比较害怕的
所以
然后呢
在但是我今天在看
普通的诺末里面
我觉得
就是这就是我的一个设计原则
就是我希望通过AI
增加AI来让你有更多的思考
某种狱伤的
我觉得你是一个
你怎么那么适的
对吧
你是怎么不让我简单一点
就帮我总结的
帮我一键总结一键生成
一键认色
是
因为它不做这事
我说那有人可以走
但我不想走
我想走就是通过加了AI
你的笔记之间
建立的联系
我甚至会问你一个问题
是
你没有想到的问题
所以这是我一直在努力的方向
我我很喜欢
你在服务里面
评价的一些AI
你比如说
你现在添加一个AI动插
对
那你添加这个AI动插的话
我觉得特别好的一点是什么
就是你不是
我写了一个东西
然后你帮我自动生成
一对东西
不是帮我自动右画
也东西
对吧
你不是在做这个功能
而是你做这个AI动插
是什么呢
就是你把那些内容
把我写的内容
你去观察
然后观察完
最后给我一个建议
对吧
他不是说
不是那种彩虹替
是吧
你记得中心太好了
你怎么这么怎么样
不是这样的
而是说
我观察到你的文字
怎么怎么怎么样
然后呢
我认为你
怎么怎么怎么样
你会站在另外一个角度
给我一个
给我一个建议
我很喜欢
其实
那会儿也是一个
这也是一个产品设计
或者一个工程设计
那段
叫其实此次
其实不复打
但是我写了很久
为什么
因为它是这样的
第一点就是首先
你要去看一下
胡子哥这一销关的笔记里面
又相关笔记
它只是数学上的三关
你并不知道
它为什么
在
国际上的相关是什么
所以你要嫂一遍
找到它反复提到的事
就是刚才我讲的
生命中的暗线
你要把这个主题抽出来
然后体验一下
让它看到说
原来我记得这么多条里面
有这么一个暗线的
这是第一
第二是
鸡鱼这个暗线
鸡鱼它记得这东西
你要给它一个
它忽略调的视角
或者是给它一个反面的视角
让它来产生一个新的动查
说
好像我的知识里面
觉得一块
第三块是通过两个问题
一个是抽象的问题
一个是距象的问题
让你进一步思考
那我接下来该怎么办
最终给你一个温柔的结尾和线索
其实它是一个产品设计
虽然是一段即使死
而这里面还要比如说
如果是感性的问题
就全是感性的那种
你怎么处理成
全是理性的怎么处理
但这一切的复杂
都不能包装成了一个暗线
暗线
我觉得特别好
因为这里面包含了很多
对AI的理解
包括你过往思考的一些总结
对吧
比如说你什么东西
是你其实最多的
那可能是你女生中备
重要的事情
对吧
你关注的一个持点
第二个部分是什么呢
就是我会让你产生对抗
对吧
就是你觉得
我觉得你哪会
会好哪一地方是不好的
对吧
我给你一些相应的建议时的
就好像我们今天
在聊天
我觉得你可能有会有这种感受
就是我们俩的聊天
说其实四个人
是
我甚至有一个人
对
对吧
咱俩聊的时候
然后这个人看着我们俩聊
对
黄镜比较
那我会快速进运作
对
所以其实那个AI冬茶
有些时候他
也是站在另外一个角度
对吧
然后来看来看待
把我
这个人
真的当作是一个我
然后我来观察你
我
是一个具体人
所思所想
然后有那些问题
然后我们可以有那些感谢
对
就是这里面就是
有点像山北腰四手的那一款
我影响特别深刻
对他会说
自我是不存在的
是
对真正的自我
是你在很多
跟高手的对抗中
慢慢显露出来那个形状
是的
对所以我觉得也一样的
就是如果我今天让AI当一个
是冒绿当个天狗
太容易了
冒绿天狗
对吧
它是很常的一个
它是很常的
那把你按摩的集体舒服
但这里面我们希望
是有一些对抗的
对
我希望他让你没有那么的舒服
所以这是我们设计的缘点
然后后面还有缘展
把他还有缘展
你还可以做什么
我看到那个服务里面
我自己特别喜欢的
我是因为这个
对的
就是我会记录一个东西
然后记录完了以后的话
他会有一个相关
相关比较
然后那个相关比起出来的时候
他会把过去
我所有的类似的东西
到的笔记拿出来
哇这个东西就特别好的什么呢
两点
第一点他会给你一个时间线
是
对吧
我们就理解
我们去理解
支持就是过去的支持
我现在又怎样重新理解
把他连在一起
有一条时间线放在那
我觉得有一些说支持是这样的
所以我把它成了一个支持的版本
是的
这个支持的版本
这是第一个部分
第二个就是
支持的联系
是
支持广纪没有用
我记得
乔布斯所过这么一句话说
所谓的创新
就是把两个看起来
好不相关的手联系在一起
那么这个东西就要创新
那那个
起来就是
我会突然发现这个相关指示
就是让你在
这个联系里面去建立联系
对
你说到这个东西
特别有意思
我看到很多
这种不相关的
这种行业里面
都有很多的帮助
我会举一个例子
就是
当时我们不是做
那个
都大家觉得
这是一个真实的
能力
就是
你在星巴克或者在零售行里面
有个概念叫神秘访客
就是
今天老百姓来简察或者某个人
要来简察你
不知道是谁的
装作用顾客
养这顾客特别是
是
然后以后是挑给侧
让人服务不好
你又不知道是谁
可能在真的是这些挑作的顾客
也可能真的是总部来的
所以你就会
紧张
对吧
然后那个神秘访客
他也会故意调整掉的
你看看
你这基本服务
我们做到位
让计计对吧
给你打个分
这是零售行里的事
我们当时在做一个
医生跟换者
不通的平坦
医生的服务
我们怎么就考核了
不怎么考核一个
然后医生经常说
没事
就是这块钱
打了一堆换
没事
不是
你去医院吗
换着就一头火
花了九个块钱
你过两字
没事
对吧
然后我们怎么办
我们就说
我们也对医生的
那种进行抽产
对
然后也是说
会有神秘的
专家医生
来抽产
你的回答
那专家只能说
那就说任事
你专业有没有问题
你专业有问题
我就任业你不行
然后你一个问题
给三个人
有一个人塞弄
就说不行
你就任专业问题
他不能出错的
他不能说
三句两句两句
一学是有标准的
那你就不行
不行
我们从零售行里面
这些呢
这个东西过来
来确保我们一条团业度
但是在医疗行里
本身
是没有这个东西的
医疗行里是没有这个
这个神秘反客户的
这少我不知道
对
但是
做着这种快借的
只是脸
就是非常非常假的
就是很多时候
真正的支持
来自于这个银之外
是的
我要准备开始
跟一些
很细节很细节很细节很细节很细节很细节很细节
然后真正创业的人
或做产品的人
国家产品会很喜欢
这个
对
你再准备做服务的
是之前
你做过那些调查吗
我做了挺多调演的
因为这是一个
两成很多年的习惯
就是做用户的
定性和定量
定性的话
我会
就是当时办公室
有很多人
然后我会尽量找
因为有当时我们是
互联网家义了
所以有一些是
一学生或者从
一两个体系里过来的人
他们对互联网的使用水平
是偏低的
不是像我们说天天用那种
什么各种各种
各种高达上的整理
是软件吗
然后你就看
我就会
你看开会
开会特别好
开会就会
就会一起努力
是的
给我看看你做了啥
然后一看就是日期
或者微明明
空航
或者第一句话
对吧
然后自在白王路
我看白王里
那你问那两个
白王里
两个我那两个工作生活没了
工作生活组组组组
对多三个
然后
我就知道
然后你就会办特别好
大量做运应的人
都是在用白王路
然后呢
好一点的人
可能会当时用点什么文章
什么
对对对
然后呢
再好一点
可能会用用一项笔戏
然后各别像
我这种什么产品经理
然后接触的
他会用什么
楼水
然后呢
你就会一直在观察
然后来
你甚至会观察说
他们很多人
用文件成为助手
对
你留意就特别好
就不对
就是
那边已经是楼水了
已经是
跨儿几个
对
已经是这种什么发展面接了
这边他用文件成为助手
然后你那块就很
突然间你会意识到一个事情
那次教演员
我会发现
大多数普通人
一辈子都是要寄冬寄
但是可能人
你辈子都不会写一个文章
是的
但这里面
达了PSE好
我了也好
几套的笔经理好
他是为
他是从打字机也面固
对吧
你可以大小
自号,航航航舰
就断年就断落着途
但是
如果我一辈子都不要写文章
我要写个文章
我一辈子总得计点事吧
但我一辈子
为辈子要写
天文章给老板看
或不给人看
或是发发的老板上
所以那是第一个东卡
说
好像能需要计动写
但他并不是要能住到一个东写
对
那第二部
就是你去严重
你定性的想法
我们就发文件吧
对
然后当时我们要做过新卵品
然后就是
你现在调了文件
就可以得到一个
这个将来什么好处啊
什么之类啊
我们说起的一万份这样的问题
对
然后在这里面数据严重了
有将近一半以上的人
都是用国背望的后面的传出手和微信小号
那我们就在想说
那能不能有一个简单的
就像微博一样的一个产品
让它快速都把自己想法记下来
是人在微信里面都可以直接说
你都不用下一步
你直接对微信数据开始的
所以才有了这个俗末的第一版的难道
所以你在微信里书的那个
可能就来自于文件注绉
是的
我心装的一旦
对当时我们最大的全身点
就是不用下爱法
你就可以记彼自己
这个我觉得可能对你来说
当时还是一个很重要的
是
对吧
很大的小姐一点
对
而且我刚才听到一个什么问题的
就是我去听那个文件调查
然后我你听完以后
你未来就可能会使用那一款产品
我就听到了我们做产品的一个一个一个一个一个英俗
那我就问一个问题啊
这开始你的用户怎么来了
这开始的用户其实
后两批在你的打开工作圈
打一条
没几个点
好
来吧
大家比如乎这个关系好
来来来我这种新单级发给你用一下
对
非常开心的
前一百个人都
都是朋友全人
都是朋友啊
都是朋友都全你别做了
对
所以朋友的话不能听
就都说
上台你
你要不
来我公司吧
就是第一反应
你要不来
你要没啥事干你来我公司吧
对吧
可是你要么去什么公司吧
然后你神经病嘛
对
2020年了
你要做一款笔记产品
你老的
当然他没说我老的了
有什么东西啊
他觉得说你可能跟人进水了
对
然后
但这块就是你自己信不信嘛
我是觉得说那没关系
因为我都知道
相对来讲这帮朋友们可能
就是不用更硬好的东西
是
对吧
那我就慢慢找嘛
你总不有人
喜欢的
对
当然当时还有一个很重要的给有干净
我当然跟我的拨火龙我们
设置了一个直思一点
跟这儿很理心的一个方法
对
我们当时是年初开始开发
然后四月份上限
对
然后我们原定第一年的年末
我们是一个解察点
一个里程备
不管好不好
那些特别厚
是要不要冠庭这个上
对
因为我们不可能无限着的投入
然后那时候我也跟我老婆说
那我可能
这半年
我这一年我不往家里拿钱
但是我可能
就是需要一个生活费
是我吃饭饭的饺
去了
他们没有别的要投入的
我先职气半年
然后看一看能不能成
如果针半年啥做不出来
能不能合作也有终套
那就该找工作找工作去
我听到了一个特别好的
就是做事也好投资也好
的这个方法
就是在我做事之前
我会有一个职讯的
我们在投资的时候叫职讯单
就是你买个的时候
你要在什么时候
如果不行就出场
是
就是我人气我做不场
我觉得特别好
这是一个很好的一个点
我就这次
这次我们说创业
他有你一个很装的点
以前创业是热情
机请你要
发一提你要改变世界
你有这种动力
没关系就是
机请是让你做出绝策的
但是整个世界的运转是靠李星来一样
所以你机请说
我做作为了给东西
我不服输别人
一对人都拒绝
我一个人都买我没关系
我给机续的
但李星来讲你要生活
你要吃饭
你要付价听责任
是的
所以你必須設一個紙紛點
你要不去影響那件事情
你確保自己不掛的
對 確保自己的家庭不崩
對 保證叫有句話叫流的青春日愛不怕
沒有 但這個話有另外一個邏輯
就是說
一旦你能保證你的成本
你還可以樣子一三四地四次的去嘗試
對 所以當時那一會兒有一個最重要的決策
就是我們設了一個紙紛點
然後就繼續找吧
你就有時間了 對吧
一百個人沒事 兩百個人沒事 兩百個人沒事
對 讓這時候當時這是一方面另一方面
就是我會寫大量的文章
這也是一種推廣的手段
很多人做第一次推廣就是說
我我我做了一個成本產品
是 你以來下 是的
這時候就會很像就是你乎
你是誰 譬如是嗎 對吧
當時我當時也寫這篇文章
你看完之後 你可以補下我的產品
但是這篇文章本身對你有價值
所以當時我寫了很多這樣的東西
就在各種網站上可以投稿吧
什麼支戶啊 可能當時也沒去發展
我說那一個能有類似的平臺
都不然你就法說我有這麼一個想法
或者我有這個認知
當時比如我們是基於卡片筆記嘛
是的 卡片筆記就這些方法有這些東西
然後我聽講完了
我做了一個小產品你要不要來試一講
是 你可以試一試 不是
當時其實是通過這樣補斷補斷補斷
對外的講這些理念
講這些真正有知識的東西
反而代表的第一批用
對 這裡有聽到雷養格點
第一個點就是認知檢訪
就是這個認知檢訪
不一定是你自己的認知檢訪
包括你周邊的環境的人認知檢訪
當你做這個時候
其實你周邊的人人都是使用鬧神的
他照顧都是這樣啊 是不是
我都說你做這麼好的
你為什麼要自己做一個女神經病嗎
是 所以有些時候
就是人一定要偷偷自己的認知識
就是你真正的偷偷
是在你的弱不安心 而不是想不安心
所以你要學會去接觸共同的弱關係
就是不要舉現在這個認知檢訪
這個認知檢訪就是剛才我說的
除了自己之外 還有你身邊的朋友了 是
這是第一件事情
然後第二件事情就是說在什麼呢
就是我我們又回到做的產品的時候
我很早也立出來這麼一個靈魂
就是你去給別人分享你的知識和經驗的時候
這其實是反而最好的或許你或是的反而
因為你現在
你把你自己放在一邊 你是幫到他
他認可你的順手你再給他一個工具
沒錯
這是一個很順利的
而且之前我們的推廣就是
就所謂我不很不喜歡那位照增長
黑客的概念是技巧
就比如說你現在我們在小空經常見
就是一個貼子 對吧 下面突然說
垃圾還不如什麼什麼什麼
對吧 很可能大多數都是脫
你會看到很多那種軟件裡面
下面都是這種
但是什麼什麼不幸還不如什麼
什麼時候不幸還不是
五六個六個六個六個五個個個個個
根本你們能放個方式嗎 是的
我要麼要麼是黑對手
我要麼是磚控的
讓我覺得這些都短期內肯定很錢層次的
短期內肯定不下
你跑不長遠 因為這個方法
它不長遠它沒有正式 對 是
然後剛才你講的
除了那兩個點
我就還有一個我想說的
就是你的灰心
你的感性上一定是灰心的
因為連人都在拒絕拒絕
是的 但是你有理性
理性就是這一萬份樣本放來的
百分之五十分都在用文件程度什麼
然後呢這邊人都是拒絕拒絕你
你現在如果你沒有這個文件
你肯定就拒絕了 是的
你如果沒有掉眼你就是算了
大家都像我不行 我就算了
但是理性數據是放來的
數據是不會作假的
而且你的樣本已經達到統計學意義了
所以我就會覺得說那一定是我
沒有找到方法 是的
來去處達到這些 或者打動這些人 對
所以我覺得這是一個
很多時候我們比如說心理會搖擺
或者這些東西
很核心的一個點
就是你有沒有一些理性的東西
在執程中的事情
我看起來馬遜啊
就是被我思可能在做決策的時候
那不就一個要求
它的決策要基於數據 是
必須是基於數據
然後數據有沒有你的
我們不認為兩對不起
尊重數據 我覺得這個很好
而且剛才我們其他一個什麼的邏輯
就是真的在今天這個社會裡面
我們使用自媒體
也有說我寫文章也好
然後我們放視頻也好
其實把我的理念傳達出的時候
本來就是有測試 是
對吧
然後跟你這個測試
反正回來再去改進我的英文產品
對 這是很多人會說
就會覺得說那你們是做互聯網
你沒有辦法
你有朋友圈你有數據什麼的
我覺得有分滿
比如當時我們開電的時候
雖然開電很失敗
但是我們也是做了很多的事情
我真的是蹲在一個地方門口
蹲了一星期
就是在技術
我要氣這個地方的地方
都會有人來 都有人去
有多少人進到電影店
有多少人去的東西
就蹲門口 我們三個人都沒有
你不要說說你們有什麼
特殊其他能拿出去
對 本單法就是去數人頭
對 本文法就是一篇篇的範
本文法就是一個一個反規的招
我覺得都是存在的
就是看你願沒有停努力了
對 我也為同意這一點
就是我們很多時候
任何AI一起幫我解決一個問題
很多時候其實是我用最笨的辦法的跑攻
然後我才知道
哪個地方是應該是應該是要進的
而且這些理性的東西
你是不是始終有辦法被獲得到的